Hey, y'all,
and welcome to the
seventh enterprise community meetup,
where we talk about end to
end data science workflows with Posit Team.
My name is Simon Couch, and
I work on free and open source
packages for machine
learning and r at Posit.
In today's session,
I'm gonna walk through
an example of training and
deploying a machine
learning model.
I'll be leaning heavily
on the tidymodels,
which is a framework for
machine learning and r that I
work on to develop my model.
Along the way,
I'll show you how Posit Team
eases some of the pain points
of model development
that I encounter.
During today's session,
I'll lay out three high level
steps for building a machine learning model.
And then spend some time
with each of those steps
individually before concluding with
resources where you can
learn more about tidymodels
and about Posit team.
After I present, we'll be
hanging out for a live Q and A.
So please feel free to
ask questions as we go,
and I'm looking forward
to spending time.
But with all that
out of the way,
let's go ahead and get started.
To talk about those
first and second steps,
I'll make use of some slides.
And then for step three,
I'll drop into a live demo
using Posit Connect and Posit Workbench.
If you're interested in
spending more time with these
slides or checking out the
source code behind this presentation,
you can go to the link
in the footer of these slides. That's
github.com/simonpcouch/mutagen.
I've put together a diagram of
sort the high level process for
developing a machine
learning model.
And the three steps that I'm
talking about are kind of
called out with these three
hex stickers in the corners.
In the top right corner, that
first step is to collect data
and to spend time with it.
Cleaning data, visualizing
it, understanding it,
are all important first steps
to building a machine learning
model. When I do
each of those steps,
I end up spending a lot
of time with the tidyverse packages.
Which some of you
may have heard of.
Once I move on to training
and evaluating models,
I use the tidymodels packages, which
I work on day to day.
And a common issue that
people run into when they're building
models with tidymodels or
any model development software is,
running out of
computational resources.
If you're working in an
environment with lots of data
or you're trying to evaluate
really complex models,
you can run out of
computational resources really
quickly. And for me, this is a
place where Posit Workbench is really key.
Recently I've started using it
when I run into this situation,
and it allows me to
drop into a computational environment where
I have more resources and can
complete that model training more quickly.
Once a model is trained,
it's time to get it into
the hands of people that will use
it. And that's where
the vetiver package comes in.
Vetiver is free and open
source, and it provides tools
to version models, deploy
models, and monitor them to
ensure that they continue to
perform as you expect them to
once they're out
into the world.
Vetiver is tightly integrated
with Posit Connect. Which
offers all sorts of tooling
for, getting the outputs of
analysis into the right hands.
So first, let's talk about
what do I even mean when I say,
machine learning or,
machine learning model?
One example is a Netflix
movie recommendation.
If you've ever gone to
somebody else's house,
and seeing the movies that
are recommended to them,
you might notice that they're
quite different than what you
might see at your own house.
That's because the movies that
are recommended to you and the
thumbnails that are part
of those recommendations
are outputs of machine
learning modesl.
And based on your viewing
history and the things that
you've said you're
interested in,
Netflix will recommend
different movies to you.
Another example,
on Zillow, if you're looking
at houses or apartments,
their estimates of the,
value of the property or the
rent that they would expect you
to pay if you were
to live there.
So that's another example
of a machine learning model
or email spam filters. So,
all of our emails whenever we
get an email at first, there's
a filter that looks at
the subject line. And if you've
received an email from
that person, before.
And if there are any
typos inside of the email,
and based on
information like that,
a model will try to predict
whether an email is spam or
not. And if it does predict
that the email is spam,
it will go to a folder.
So the thing that all of
these share is that they are guessing
the value of an outcome
using predictors.
For example, in the
email spam filters,
the outcome is whether
that email is spam or not.
And the predictors are
those things I mentioned,
like the subject line,
and the number of typos
inside and other things like that.
For a Zillow property
value estimate,
that might be something like
the square footage of the house
or the apartment. How
recently it was renovated?
What area it's in?
And for Netflix movie
recommendations,
that's things like your stated
interests in movies that you're
interested in to how long
you spent watching movies in
different subcategories.
Another example of a machine
learning model is one that this
presentation is based on.
Day to day,
my responsibility is just to
develop tools to build models.
And so I often don't spend
a lot of time building models myself.
But doing so helps us
better understand the perspectives of
our users, and so we try to
make time to really delve in on
a modeling problem
as often as we can.
So recently, my colleague, Max Kuhn
and I spent some time to,
develop a model and work through
the process to deploy it using,
Posit Workbench and Posit
Connect and wrote about that on
the Posit blog.
In this blog post,
we talk through a process
that's really similar to the
one that I'll talk through
with you today where we explore
data, we situate with our
modeling problem, we develop a
model to best understand that data,
and then we deploy it using Connect.
So the process of machine
learning with Posit team, again,
I'll just underscore those
three different sections before
we dive in on them.
First, we'll spend some time to
understand and clean
data with the tidyverse,
and then we'll train and
evaluate models with tidymodels and Workbench.
For both of these sections,
I'll just work through some
slides. And if you're interested
in the details, you can,
look at the source code of
the analysis and the source code
for these slides at
github.com/simonpcouch/mutagen.
Once we've done so, we need
to get that model into the hands
of users, and that's
where vetiver and Connect come
So let's start off
with understanding
and cleaning data.
In pharmaceuticals,
Mutagenicity refers to a drug's
tendency to increase the rate
of mutations due to
damage caused to DNA.
Mutagenicity
is a key indicator that a drug
may be a carcinogen or a cancer causing.
Mutagenicity can be evaluated
with a lab test. So,
a person can test whether
a drug is a mutagen,
using a standard
wet lab procedure,
but those tests are costly
and those tests are time intensive.
So a group of scientists
in our example problem converges to
ask the question,
what if a machine learning
model could predict
mutagenicity using
known drug information?
That is if scientists are
spending time with a new drug,
using information that they
already have they can predict
whether a drug is
a mutagen or not,
which will allow them
to iterate more quickly when
they're developing new drugs.
The source data that we'll be
working with is called mutagen table.
It's a table with over
four thousand rows and notably
over fifteen
hundred predictors.
So in this first column, we
have whether the drug is a
mutagen or whether
it's a non mutagen.
And for each of those compounds as
well, we have a whole lot of predictors,
giving us other information we
can use to predict whether a
drug is a mutagen or not.
So you're probably
thinking to yourself,
if I have fifteen hundred
little pieces of information
about this drug, it
surely must be pretty,
straightforward
to predict that.
It turns out it's not
quite that simple.
On this plot, I've plotted
two of the predictors, and,
each of those points is
also colored according to whether
the drug is actually a mutagen
or whether it's a non mutagen.
So colors in blue are mutagens.
Colors in yellow
are non mutagens.
On the x axis, we have the
molecular weight and y axis is
the partition coefficient.
It doesn't matter whether you
understand either of these two
predictors, I really don't
understand them. But,
the point here is that
it's really hard just using the
information we have here
to separate between the blue
points and the yellow points,
only knowing the value
of these two predictors.
I can choose another
two of them. Right now,
I'm showing the number of
heavy atoms and the log of the
average valence connectivity.
Whatever those two
predictors mean. Again,
we're seeing that it's really hard
to sort of draw a line
here. That would easily
separate the blue points and
the yellow points.
And this is the goal that our
machine learning model will try to solve.
So if you're like me,
you're feeling a little bit intimidated
about tackling this.
This is where we move on to
the step of training and evaluating models.
So for this portion
of the presentation,
instead of walking through the
notebook that does the training
and the evaluating, I'll,
leave it to folk to look
through the notebooks that are
on that GitHub page
after the presentation.
And instead
I'll try to answer the question
of why you might be interested
in using tidymodels over other
modeling frameworks that are out there.
The first reason why you should
be interested in using tidy
models is that tidymodels is
consistent in a way that other
modeling frameworks and
modeling packages are not.
An example that I'll use
to call this out here,
we can start off by showing
the code to fit a linear
model using the LM
function with tidymodels.
And a linear model using
only the LM function.
On the left hand side,
there's just one line of code.
We're using the example
MC card dataset here,
if you're familiar with it,
we're saying we want to
use all of the predictors on
in the mtcars data.
To predict the outcome, which is
the miles per gallon, or MPG.
And to do so, we'll
use the mtcars data.
On the right hand side,
the code does the same thing,
except the tidy model's wrapper has
been dropped on top of that function.
The code reads will
use a linear regression
using the LM function as
our computational engine
and we'll fit that model using,
the same dataset and the
same pre processing formula
miles per gallon as a
function of everything.
So when you see
this, you might think
it seems a whole lot easier
to just go ahead and use lm.
It's only one line of
code, and I hear you.
Where we really see the value
of tidymodels though is when we
start to introduce complexity
into the modeling pipeline.
So let's say you're using the
LM function and it's not doing
everything you need it to
do, and you want to add, for
example, a regularization
term to your linear regression.
If you're not
familiar with that,
doesn't matter to understand
what I'm about to demonstrate
here. I want you to look
at that line three in
the tidy models portion of the code
where I've set the engine to LM.
If
I want to transition that
code to instead use Glmnet,
all that I need to do is change
the the portion of the code
that said LM to
instead say Glmnet.
And you can see on
the left hand side,
It was much more than just
one of the lines of code that
needed to change.
Instead here, Glmnet
for its first argument is going
to take all of the predictors
and they can only be a
matrix. So thankfully here in mtcars.
All of the predictors are
numbers anyway, and so they're
one homogeneous type and we
can easily convert it with as.matrix.
And then instead of the name
of the outcome variable, like it
was in LM, the
outcome here is
specified as the actual,
vector of values in the
mtcars data set. So that's
mtcars$mpg.
To transition that code, I
needed to know not only the
Glmnet existed and was able
to perform regularization,
but I needed to look at
the documentation to see how that
function wanted
predictors to be formatted,
how it wanted the
outcome to be formatted,
whether it needed any
additional arguments which of
the functions in the package
I needed to use to do so.
And again, in tidymodels, all
I needed to do was change the
value of that engine argument.
And the story goes the same way
with any other engine you can imagine.
Let's say instead of Glmnet, I
wanted to use the H2O package,
which gives me access
to all sorts of,
machine learning techniques
implemented in Java,
so it's super fast.
With tidymodels,
all I need to do is change
the value of engine to
h20.
But with h2o, I need
to initialize an h2o
server I need to convert
that mtcars data set to a
data set that's
compatible with h2o using
as.h20
and I assign a label to
that mtcars data set, the string
mtcars, and then I pass that
string as the last argument to
h20s linear model function
h20.glm.
Also, the h20.glm
function doesn't take the
values of the predictors,
instead it takes the names.
So I take the names
of the mtcars dataset,
the portion of it that
has the predictors in it,
and the same goes
for the outcome.
It takes the name of the outcome
in the mtcars dataset as a string.
So all of this, change
in the code. Again,
I would need to spend time to,
read through the documentation,
see how that interface changes,
And only once I've done so,
can I make use
of the functionality within H2O?
And with tidymodels,
I just get that for
free by changing the engine argument.
Another reason to
use tidymodels is safety.
Tidymodels is designed to,
safeguard you from common
modeling pitfalls.
One of the things that
tidymodels is designed to
protect you from is data
leakage. A 2023 review found
data leakage to be a widespread
failure mode in machine
learning based science.
Data leakage is
when information
from the set you're going
to use or the portion of the
data that you're going to
use to evaluate your model somehow
leaks into the portion of the data
that you're using to train your model.
If a model is being evaluated
on data that it's seen already,
then it will perform better than
on data that it hasn't seen before.
And so it will seem like your
model is performing really
well, but it's actually not,
and you'll only learn that
the model isn't performing well
once it's deployed.
So in our example,
in the mutagen example,
if our model seems to
be able to classify
drugs as either mutagens or
non mutagens really, really well.
If we go ahead and deploy that,
thinking that the model is
performing perfectly, then,
scientists will mistakenly
interpret the results
from that model and,
take them at face value.
Another common failure
mode is overfitting.
Overfitting leads to analysts
believing models are more
performant than
they actually are.
So this is really similar
to that first failure mode, where,
in the case of an overfit
model, in our mutagen example,
the model is going to perform
really, really well on,
the portion of the data that
was used to train the model And
if we don't have tools to
then evaluate the model on data that
it hasn't seen before, then,
that model might just learn
every little intricacy of
the training data and won't
generalize well to data
that it hasn't seen before.
A last component of safety that,
tidymodels makes sure to
protect its users from is
irreproducibility
implementations
of the same machine learning
model give differing results in many,
popular implementations of
machine learning algorithms
resulting in irreproducibility
of modeling results.
So each of the citations listed
in the bottom here in order are,
reports on data leakage
and over fitting and
irreproducibility.
And tidymodels is designed to
safeguard you from all of them.
We develop this software so
that it's really hard to do the
things that are wrong and
that an analyst would commonly want
to do and makes the things
that are usually difficult,
but pay off in the long it
makes those things really easy.
Another reason why you
might wanna use tidymodels,
is that tidymodels is
designed to be communicable.
All tidymodels objects,
or at least many of
them have visualization functions called
autoplot that are
associated with them.
So if I make a,
receiver operating curve
with the tidy models,
which is a tool used to,
evaluate models, I can pass
that object to autoplot and
see what that curve looks
like in 2D space.
I can also pass, for example,
the result of trying to tune a
random forest algorithm. Again,
I just passed that result
to the autoplot function,
and we have built
in visualization procedures for that.
Model object.
The same story goes
for iterative search results,
things like bayesian
optimization,
simulated annealing.
These are advanced machine
learning techniques that are
built into tidymodels When
I use tidymodels to generate
these results, I can understand
them by quickly plotting them.
Another example to use
tidymodels is completeness.
There's built in support
for ninety nine machine models,
once you load the
tidymodels packages,
and there are even more
packages if you load extensions
that are contributed
by the community.
Tidymodels is also complete
with reference to data pre
processing techniques.
With the three main packages
for pre processing that are
loaded when you
load tidymodels,
we load in a hundred and two
different ways to process
data that comes in raw and
turn it into something that a model
knows what to do with.
And I've hinted at this
already, but again,
tidymodels is extensible.
If you can't find the
machine learning technique you need,
which is either the machine
learning model or the pre
processing technique, you
can add it yourself. We have
APIs that are designed to
make it really easy to contribute
your own extensions that
are designed with your problem
context in mind.
The last reason I'll list
here is deployability,
and this will bring us into
that final step three that will
drop into the live demo for.
Tidymodels is tightly
integrated with vetiver,
which is a free and
open source package for model deployment.
And vetiver is configured to
quickly and easily and securely,
ship a model to Posit Connect,
which is part of the suite
of products in Posit Team.
So that said, let's go ahead
and drop into a live demo.
I'll spin up a Workbench
session and we'll use that
session, to train a model and
then send it off to Posit Connect.
Once I've logged in,
this is what my Posit
Workbench instance looks like.
I'm gonna start out by
spinning up a new session,
and this is what I was talking
about where I can get access to
resources beyond
what my laptop is capable of
in terms of computing power.
So I have access to,
different types of clusters and then,
for that cluster,
different options in terms
of the number of CPUs and the
amount of RAM.
So I'm gonna go ahead and
start this session an RStudio Pro project.
This will just take a
couple seconds to spin up.
And once it's wrapped up,
it will look a lot like,
an instance of the RStudio IDE
if you've ever worked with one
of those locally
on your laptop.
So from here, I'm at the
point where I have some code
that I want to use to train
a model. And this code is
hosted on,
this GitHub repository
that I have here.
github.com/simonpcouch/mutagen.
This repository has all the
source code for training the
model, as well as the
source code for the slides.
If you're interested in it. And
I'm going to go ahead and copy
the link to this
GitHub repository.
And then I will
start a new project.
And
the new project will be
from version control.
I'll start it up from git
and paste in the URL there,
and I'll call this project mutagen.
This will also just take a
couple seconds to spin up. And
once it's done, so all of the,
data and the source files that
were inside of that GitHub repository
are going to be also,
available to me inside
of Posit Workbench.
So for instance, there's
a README in this repository,
giving some high level
information on what's in there.
Here's all the source code for
the slides in the slide folder.
What I'm gonna open up is,
source here, which has a quarto
document that has all of the
source code that I used to, pre
process my data and start
understanding in step one. And
then moving into that
step two, which is,
developing and training the
model and ultimately deciding
on the final fit.
So you can see up here
in my environment, I went ahead and,
loaded in the output
of final_fit from file.
So normally in my workflow,
I would go ahead and train
the model here on Workbench And
since I've done so already,
I already have the output
of that from here. And instead,
we're gonna move right on
to that last step, step three
which is getting that trained
model into the hands of the
people that are
going to use it.
This is actually really simple.
There's only a few
lines of code you need.
Once you have a fitted
model with tidymodels,
to then go ahead and
deploy that model to, Posit Connect.
The first step is to pass
that trained model to vetiver
model, which is a
function from vetiver,
which will put some wrappers
around it and make sure it's
ready to go to deploy.
I'll also call board_connect here
and assign that output to board.
If you're unfamiliar with this
function, this is from pins.
And,
if you wanna learn more
about the pins package,
I think it was the last,
Posit Team demo where
they covered the functionality there.
So we're running
into an error here,
and what this is telling me
is that we don't have a Posit
Connect server that we're
connected to already.
So we can actually
go ahead and do that,
and it's pretty simple. If
I go to tools, global options,
publishing.
These are the, the accounts
from which I can publish from.
So I'm gonna go ahead and
just click connect here to Posit Connect.
And this is prefilled for
me because I'm working on my
workbench instance,
inside of a Posit Team.
Account.
So that's prefilled in
there. I'll click next.
It's gonna wait
for authentication.
And it will authenticate
to my Posit account.
And now that it's,
authenticated,
I can click connect account.
And apply.
And so that's all I needed
to do to link my Workbench session
up to Posit Connect.
So I can try
running that board_connect code again,
and it was successful.
Nice.
So I'm on the connect instance
that I have access to through Posit.
I will then pass that final
fit object that vetiver made to
me, to vetiver_pin_write, to write it
to the board I've just created.
And now that final _fit_vetiver
object is pinned to the board
on Posit Connect.
So once that, pin is on
Connect, I'll go ahead and
deploy the model that I have,
assigned to this
Simon.couch/mutagen
And you'll see here down in
the console that vetiver is doing
all sorts of work to,
bundle up everything that
that model needs to create
predictions from new data, into
an object that can
be passed off to connect.
So that happened pretty
quickly. It just,
brought us over to a connect
window, where, vetiver
is showing the deployment.
So the,
on the left side of the screen
is what a user see if they have
pulled up this model API.
And so there's all sorts
of metadata about the model.
There's examples from
which analysts can ping,
put together code to ping the
model for new predictions.
And then on the right
side, and this is,
a really nice benefit
for a lot of people.
There's all sorts of access
to security features and metadata.
So, by default, it's only,
available to specific
users or groups,
and you can add those in,
but you can also make it
available to all users within
your organization.
And then there's all
sorts of other metadata
you have access to, as well.
So I hadn't deployed a
model using vetiver until, I was
working on the blog post
that I mentioned earlier,
and I was really surprised
at how straightforwardly it came together.
And so I would
encourage you if you,
are working in an instance
of workbench in your organization
to go ahead and try to
do that same thing, deploy the model,
that is, publicly available on
my GitHub and see what happens.
So with the third step of
deploying our model wrapped up,
we've really touched on all
portions of this diagram at
this point. At first, we
took a look at our data. We
situated ourselves with
the modeling problem,
We visualized some of the
variables and got a sense of
the challenge that
we were up for.
We then moved on to training
and evaluating a model, using tidymodels.
In this demo,
we really just talked about
why using tidymodels would be
advantageous to your
modeling workflow.
But if you're more interested in
how we actually went about doing that,
I would encourage you to pull
down that script I had up
during the demo, run
some of the code and,
see how it feels for you.
And I'll show you some
resources after this where you
can learn more how
to use tidymodels.
After that, we went on
to deploy the model to Posit
Connect using Vetiver
And as you saw,
that really only took
a couple lines of code.
So we very quickly went from
a final trained model to a
model that's in the hands
of users at our organization.
If you're interested
in learning more,
to learn more about tidyverse,
how to understand and clean
and visualize data. The r for
data science book at
r4ds.hadley.nz Is definitely a great
place to start. And if
you feel comfortable with those
foundations and wanna move on
to the modeling portion, the
tidy modeling with our book at
tmwr.org. It's a great
resource and can bring you from
a beginner to a strong
modeler very quickly.
If you wanna learn more about
Posit Team, I would head to
Posit.co/team. There's all sorts
of information on the
products that are, included
as part of Posit Team and,
links for places to learn more.
And lastly, if you wanna
see these slides again or poke
around with the source code
that's underneath them or poke
to train a model using tidymodels
Again, that, code is at
github.com/simonpcouch/mutagen.
I really appreciate
the welcome to,
drop into the Posit Team demo.
Thank you for having me, and,
looking forward to questions.
Thanks so much, Simon.
Really appreciate you joining us
here today for the demo and
for sticking around
for the q and a.
Just wanted to let everybody
know that this YouTube will
push you over to the live q
and a in just a second here But
if you want to ask questions,
you can post in the YouTube
chat over there,
but you can also use the slido
link that we have up on the
screen. So you
can ask questions anonymously
if you go to
pos.it/demo-questions
But one thing that I wanted
to add is that we have these
monthly end to end work flow
demos on the last Wednesday of
every month. So if you joined
us here today for your first
one, we'd love to have
you join us again.
And so you can add those to
your calendar with just the short link
pos.it/team-demo and
that add to calendar link will point
you to all the recordings as well.
But we'll see you over there
in the q and a. Just a second.